you
welcome to this press conference where
will will present this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry this year's prize is
about taking the chemical experiment to
cyberspace the Royal Swedish Academy of
Sciences has decided to award the 2013
Nobel Prize in Chemistry to Professor
Martin corpus at the University of
Strasbourg France and Harvard University
Cambridge Massachusetts you saw and
professor Michael Leavitt at Stanford
University School of Medicine California
USA and professor Ari Marshall at
University of Southern California Los
Angeles USA and the Academy citation
runs for the development of multi scale
models for complex chemical systems